[Music]
i'm really eager to to get started now
it's been
it's been long
and besides i think
i feel like i played like maybe one good
event last season apart from that i feel
like it was just always a struggle
that's
partly because others were playing
really really well and giving me a huge
fight but
i want to do want to do better and
want to get started on a high notes and
you played a lot of chess lately the
three world championships taught us the
last two weeks how's your form how are
you feeling
i'm feeling feeling okay tata still was
uh
was a great experience for for me
it's really
[Music]
the first classical tournament
in a very long time that i feel that i
actually played well i'm
not expecting to have a huge surplus of
energy i think that's anyway
kind of hard in the winter but
i i think that my chest shape is in
general
um
pretty good so i really hope i can build
on that for
for the next 10 minutes and who are you
expecting to be so the shining stars of
the champions just for this season
i think
the people who did well
last year might do do well again
if they play obviously um
[Music]
apart from that uh i'll be eager to see
how yes panko can can do since he didn't
play last year and he's shown serious
flashes of what he can do in in
classical chess um
artemiev is going to have a full season
uh hopefully instead of
the brief chances that he had last year
a lot of candidates